the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
that migration hit 606 000 driven by
people arriving from Hong Kong and
Ukraine
Germany unexpectedly goes into recession
after a surprise fall in first quarter
GDP
take long hits a sweet spot as profit
sword despite higher costs
and a big step forward in the Quest for
Net Zero as a British company breaks his
own record for solar cell efficiency
thank you
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well figures released
in the last half hour or so show that
net migration hit 606 000 last year the
office for National statistics says
people arriving from outside the
European Union for work study and
humanitarian reasons have contributed to
relatively high levels of immigration
over the past 18 months or 1.2 million
people entered the UK on a long-term
basis while 557
000 emigrated bringing net migration to
606 000. most people arriving for non-eu
Nationals numbering almost a million
following uh followed by EU Nationals
and britons who are joining me now is
Kate shoe Smith she's deputy chief
executive of the Recruitment and
employment Confederation Kate welcome to
you I mean the number is actually
significantly lower than the expected
have we all been a party to a bit of
expectations management by the
government
I do Wonder
um I think the key here is that the
comparison that people were using is
previously uh migration was around the
net migration figure was around the
quarter of a million Mark uh last year
we obviously saw a big increase on that
and then we've seen again an increase in
the last year but I think it's really
important to think of the context here
so we are in an unprecedented period of
Labor and skill shortages our data shows
that we currently have around 1.7
million job vacancy postings out there
that are not being filled it's not going
to be enough to think about the UK
talent that can solve those roles so we
have to have an efficient and responsive
migration system alongside it
to what extent do you think that some of
the arrivals over the last 12 months
have been able to alleviate those
problems in the labor market because a
lot of these people won't necessarily be
allowed to work will they no and and
actually one of the growth figures that
is contributed to to what we're seeing
as um and I'm um this this high level of
net migration is refugees coming in from
some different countries but notably
from Ukraine and Hong Kong has been has
been recognized by uh the government
this morning now that has to be the
right response that we're bringing in
people and if Asylum Seekers are
considered in the numbers the the time
it takes for Asylum Seekers to be
um their claims to be reviewed is is
considerable and actually one of the
things that stops those people that come
to this country with with significant
experience and lots of different skill
sets from working is the fact that you
have to be an asylum Seeker for over 12
months before you can work surely we can
do something to cut that down so that
these people can be contributing to the
economy much sooner we'd like to see it
six months actually
or the government is looking to restrict
the ability of some overseas students to
bring in family members do we have any
idea on those family members who are
already here the extent to which they're
participating in the labor markets it's
not clear from from today's numbers but
we do know that when people come to to
the UK they want to come and live and
study and work here and we have to make
it an attractive country as possible
like I said we we have unprecedented
labor and skills demands in this in this
country they were exacerbated by the
pandemic and by um the coming out of
lockdowns and we haven't seen a decline
in that demand from employers to hire
staff so if we're going to make the UK
the right place to come the right place
to be a global trading partner we have
to think about our labor and skills
system but we have to think about
migration policy alongside that it's
really important that we get those two
sides of the same coin working together
now the labor party said yesterday if it
wins the next general election it's
going to Bar employers from hiring
foreign laborers unless it pays them
what it calls the going rates whatever
whatever that is I mean what sort of
impact will that have on the labor
market
it'll be interesting to understand those
proposals in a bit more detail we
already have the national living wage
the the national minimum wage that is
set by government
um that is recommended to them each year
that's the obligation that is on
employers so if that's not being met
what should be happening is there should
be the proper mechanisms to enforce the
regulations and to enforce the proper
pay rates if we're not putting the money
aside for proper enforcement that's a
problem because it really doesn't help
the good businesses that are trying
their best out there to to pay their
workers to support good working
practices and and it's not fair that the
Rogue Traders are getting the upper hand
in any way
I mean as politicians being unrealistic
in some ways Kate I mean we keep hearing
that they want to uh get British workers
to do some of the jobs that we've relied
on overseas laborers for in the recent
past but with the best will in the world
we're never going to get British people
to do jobs like fruit picking are we
well you definitely do have them in some
circumstances but I think I think the
key thing is we need to think about it
in the rounds so so I I'm talking about
um job market vacancies that I can see
from the front line of working in the
recruitment industry we look at things
like the NHS waiting lists they're
they're off the charts there are over
seven million people waiting so for
treatment some of those things need to
be treated before they can be ready for
work you need to be thinking about how
you bring together work finding support
with health support but also with a
really responsible skills and training
um system that that helps employers find
the skills they need right now and and
actually sometimes you need their skills
before the training has completed that's
why you bring in migrants to do these
jobs
oh okay gotta leave it there good to
talk to you this morning thank you
now I've sold energy bills are set to
fall from the first of July after the
regulator off gem cut the energy price
cap that limits the amount that energy
supplies are allowed to charge a dual
fuel household per unit of gas or
electricity
from July the average household will now
pay 2074 pounds a year the current cap
is 3280 pounds but the government's
energy price guarantee has kept average
bills down to two and a half thousand
pounds well speaking with cape Burley
this morning off gems chief executive
Jonathan breely acknowledged that things
will still be difficult for many
we are still at the moment paying two
and a half thousand pounds a year now
there is good news that is going down to
2074 so prices are falling but you're
right when you take away all the
government support that's finishing
things are still going to be tough for
many families this winter what do you do
at home so what do I do I I have always
switched supplier when I can so it's
been a different Circumstance the last
couple of years but I always switch
supplier I always look into the market
to see the best deal for me now that for
me is not just about price that's about
the service I get and that's also about
the sort of tariffs I might want to sign
up to in the future so there's a number
of factors I look at but yes I'm an
active switcher in the market
as our business correspondent Paul Kelso
Paul no real drama here are the it's
come down more or less exactly as people
expected yes it's bang in line with the
forecast that have proved uh pretty
accurate over the last 12 months it is a
moment though Ian with it's the biggest
drop and it brings it's two things it
brings prices uh back down to a level we
haven't seen for more than a year that
2074 pounds remember that's an average
amount for typical use so that's a
family of four in a in a home uh with
enough bedrooms uh it's also crucially
below the two and a half thousand pounds
so the government has been guaranteeing
we can see how the price cap has evolved
here if you look back to the left-hand
side of the screen there the chart pre
the war in Ukraine and average a
long-term average around a thousand
pounds a year climbs as we post covered
and then uh it's summer 22 once the war
is underway in Ukraine and look how high
it went up four thousand pounds uh in
the winter but that energy price
guarantee effectively capping prices uh
with the treasury picking up the bill
everything above the line there and the
red chart there that's where the price
cup has fallen that cost of the treasury
94 billion pounds so far so the
chancellor will be pleased uh prices
have fallen back actually wholesale gas
prices are at their lowest since 2021 at
the moment which explains why consumer
prices are falling key question for
what's left of the market remember this
stat price shock has wiped out many many
of the suppliers Who provided what parts
for competition in the energy Market
many of them caught out by Rising prices
ultimately you can't get around the fact
someone's got to pay the real cost of
energy until we have major reform of
both Supply and the market we're off Gem
and some of the market observers you
switch this morning saying they think
this may bring some competition back
into the market there may be some
options for consumers looking at doing
what Jonathan Brady was talking to Kay
about this morning switching it's
effectively that two and a half thousand
pound price guarantee has been a minimum
price price for suppliers now it may
come down people may be willing to offer
fixed prices perhaps for six months or a
year where you can lock in at around
this 2 000 pound uh Mark but we wait to
see if that really does pass through
these prices will apply it from July the
outlook for the rest of the year is the
prices will remain pretty stable that's
barring any other shocks the one thing
the UK does not want is any Interruption
to liquid natural gas supply
particularly from Qatar who are who have
filled the Gap left by that huge
reduction in Russian hydrocarbons in the
energy Market the price for that sitting
at around two thousand pounds the price
of War you could put it that we're all
going to have to live with
okay Paul thanks for that
now food and drink manufacturers are
fighting to convince consumers their
products represent good value during the
cost of living crisis until that end
coming up with products that are as
tasty and healthy as possible is crucial
helping many of them in that regard is
tayton Lyle whose ingredients aim to
improve the texture and flavor of
everything from soup sauces and
dressings to breakfast cereals muffins
Juice drinks and confectionery today it
reported a pre-tax profit of 253 million
pounds on an adjusted basis that was up
13 on the same period last year the
shares are currently ahead by some two
percent joining me now is Nick Hampton
he's the chief executive of Technology
Nick good to see you again this morning
I mean inflation is obviously front of
mind right now what's happening to your
costs
uh we saw in significant increase in
input costs last year but as you say and
you saw in the results we did an
excellent set of financial results as a
result of managing those costs very well
and for us that's about driving
productivity it's about working with our
customers to provide the right kind of
value to improve product quality while
also helping them with with taking cost
out too and the balance of that resulted
in a pretty good set of results I think
how difficult or easy is it to pass on
higher costs to some of your customers
presumably a lot of them are locked into
long-term contracts
yes but with the way the way we do our
Contracting is we we look to lock in the
input costs as we see them going forward
so we'll try them back-to-back price
with Contracting forward on raw
materials so we create some certainty
about for both us and customers and
again that was a big part of managing
the consequences of inflation last year
and we're doing that as well as we come
into this year in terms of passing
through it's about working with
customers to provide value and and
recognizing that input cost inflation is
part of that equation
have there been points during the last
12 months Nick where you've been tempted
to sacrifice volumes in order to defend
your price position
we were very intentional last year about
looking to do high quality business and
what you saw is a significant increase
in Revenue versus Volume last year as a
result and that's just a continual focus
on the high value part of our business
which is driving the growth story of the
new Titan Lal so yes intentionally doing
the right kind of volume is part of the
strategy
so one of the big events this year
obviously has been the reopening of
China from its covered lockdowns what
sort of challenges has that presented
you with
well for for us it was very interesting
through the latter half of last year we
saw a big increase in infection rates in
China amongst our staff you know through
December January 60 of our staff had
covid fortunately mildly and we kept all
of our operations running and what we're
seeing now is some you know signs of
positive momentum in China as you know
we made a big acquisition there last
year and our China businesses is an
important pillar of the future
obviously the war in Ukraine has now
been waging for more than a year I mean
I know at the outset that presented
certain challenges for you in terms of
obtaining some raw materials are those
challenges starting to Abate now
things are definitely easing
um more because we've looked to Source
from elsewhere we didn't actually Source
corn or any significant raw materials
out of Ukraine but obviously there was
tightness in Europe and we're having to
bring corn into Europe from outside
still but the strength of our Global
footprint is really helping with that so
we haven't really seen any significant
challenges to production because we work
really hard to get the right kind of
global supply chain capability in place
now obviously uh you spend an awful lot
of money every year on research and
development what sort of things are
bubbling away in your Laboratories now
that people should get excited about
look I think people should be excited
about the range of innovation we're
bringing across sweeteners mouth feel
and fortification so those things
combined together really help improve
the health of food so we're putting
those things together helps take sugar
calories fat out and food but still make
it taste great and you know that taste
is at a premium for consumers so if
we're going to change consumer habits
then providing Great Taste and better
and better health balance is really
important I mean a lot of what you do is
obviously plant-based already do you
feel as though you you were kind of a
Pioneer in this field given that
everyone is now rushing into more
plant-based nutrition
I think the heritage of the businesses
for over 160 years has always been in
plant-based and that's the great
heritage to build on and we're very
clear that plant-based is the future
everything we do comes from Agriculture
and increasingly we're seeing much more
demand for those products so that reset
that we've done in the last couple of
years really has put it right at the
center of the future of food
all right Nick it's a busy day for your
results today we do appreciate you
sparing the time to speak to us thank
you my pleasure thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and Germany is officially in
recession it emerged today Europe's
largest economy contracted by 0.3
percent during the first three months of
the year according to the country's
statistical agency that came on top of a
contraction of half of one percent
during the final three months of last
year and two consecutive quarters of
economic contraction is of course the
definition of a technical recession well
earlier estimates had suggested Germany
might avoid a recession household and
government spending both fell during the
quarter and were the biggest drags on
growth the bundes bank which is
Germany's Central Bank is forecasting
modest growth during the current quarter
the continuing popularity of pet
ownership which took off during the
pandemic has propelled pets at home to
better than expected results the UK's
biggest pet care business reported an
underlying pre-tax profit of 136.4
million pounds for the air to the end of
March that was up 4.8 percent on the
previous 12 months and came on the back
of a 6.6 rise in sales to a record 1.4
billion pounds sales growth was
strongest in the company's Veterinary
arm well Lisa McGowan the chief
executive said the company grew its
active VIP base to 7.7 million averaging
more than 24 000 puppy and kitten sign
ups and eight and a half thousand new
vet clients per week
the water company United utilities has
gone into the red on the back of higher
electricity and chemicals costs lower
consumption and a surge in the cost of
dealing with the aftermath of a surge of
burst pipes during harsh winter weather
United which provides Water and
Wastewater services in the northwest of
England reported an underlying pre-tax
loss of 34.3 million pounds for the year
to the end of March that compared with a
profit of 301.9 million pounds during
the previous 12 months headline profits
meanwhile for by 42 to 256.3 million
pounds the Divinity shareholders is
being raised by 4.6 well Louise
beardmore she's the new chief executive
of United United said the company had
achieved a 39 reduction in sewage spills
since 2020 but acknowledged the need to
invest more in infrastructure assets and
employees in order to meet new
environmental targets
the security and defense contractor
kinetic said today that the increased
focus on defense spending by governments
had brought it record orders during the
last year the company which employs 8
000 people worldwide set orders Rose by
41 to 1.7 billion pounds including the
contract to deliver experimentation
tests and evaluation for the Royal Navy
submarine Fleet and want to support the
US Army with the development testing
deployment and training of digital night
vision technology underlying operating
profits during the year to the end of
March Rose by 30 to
178.9 million pounds I can tell you the
Share Price is currently ahead by some 2
percent
a rise in both customer numbers and
savings inflows help the investment
platform AJ Bell raise pre-tax profits
by 61 to 41.9 million pounds during the
six months to the end of March AJ Bell
said customer numbers Rose by seven
percent During the period to just over
455 000 while assets under
Administration grew by 7 to 73.8 billion
pounds Michael summersgill the chief
executive said it was a strong
performance during a period of
challenging market conditions he also
called on the government to simplify the
large range of Isis now available to
Savers into just a single ISO that was
easy to understand and would be more
likely to encourage investment
foreign
well guilds UK government bonds fell
sharply yesterday as the April inflation
figure came in higher than expected in
the yield which Rises as the price falls
on tenure guilts yesterday hit 4.321
percent that was the highest since
October last year short while ago it was
4.282 percent well on the equity markets
another sell-off on Wall Street last
night spot by concerns over the U.S debt
ceiling was followed by overnight
declines for equities in the Asia
Pacific region you saw those a moment
ago only Tokyo finished in positive
territory you're looking at the picture
in Europe right now
there we go that's back to Asia there
yeah the Nick a uh up by uh just under
two fifths of one percent all the other
main indices in the region lower in
Europe Equity markets also trading to
the downside this morning largely
although the Ibex in Madrid and the in
Spain is slightly higher uh the cat
coron in France more or less unchanged
right now not many features in Europe to
talk about this morning but the Spanish
travel booking Company E dreams is ahead
by some four percent in Madrid right now
after fully results came in ahead of
expectations here in London the ftse 100
is also in negative territory right now
currently off uh just under over a fifth
of one percent there's a broad-based
sell-off as ever on a Thursday at this
time of year a number of stocks have
gone X dividend this morning in other
words they've adjusted lower
automatically to reflect the fact that
they're trading for the first time
without rights to the latest payout
there's a real clutch of them in the
ftse this morning they include
Kingfisher Intertech DCC and uh
Coca-Cola HBC and Imperial Brands if you
own shares in those companies don't
worry they've all gone X div today and
that's why they appear to be uh lower
right now elsewhere in the ftse 100
Johnson Matthey the industrial materials
group it shares currently off by some
two and a half percent nearly on its
latest results on the foreign exchange
markets well a lot of the actions been
in the Euro this morning uh following
confirmation Germany has entered
recession Sterling up by just over a
quarter of one percent right now against
a single currency the Euro also off by
sixth of one percent against the US
dollar Sterling more or less unchanged
against the Greenback meanwhile up a
tenth of one percent as for the oil
price well that's been drifting a bit
this morning about a Brent crude will
currently set you back
77.46 a bow that is off a little over
one percent on the session or joining me
this morning is Patrick Spencer Vice
chair of equities at bird Patrick good
to see you this morning I know you're an
equities man but we've got to start
really with what happened in the guilt
market yesterday pretty extraordinary
yes well I think Kenny you've seen
interest rates Rises you know across
across the world you know to uh you know
combat uh inflation and I think and
there's concerns there that uh in
interest rates are going to go
considerably higher on the back of that
inflation number but if you you know the
U.S usually leads the rest of the world
with these inflation reaction numbers
and CPI there which is the main index
the FED looks at
um basically has come down from ten to
six percent and it's quite sticky in the
UK because of you know difficulties over
workers and workers comps and brexit Etc
and um you know certainly it has its own
issues of higher gas prices Etc which we
feel will eventually uh work its way
through the system so I think that's
what you're seeing really is an
overreaction to a very high print and I
looked at Futures this morning and
they're only looking for interest rates
to go just above five percent and what
are they now four and a half percent so
definitely an interest rate rise I think
next month but then we should actually
get some ease you know the market it's
the financial Futures are saying you
know we're going to see interest rates
stabilizing a little in the second half
of this year what's all it's going to
mean for company earnings I mean
obviously we've just come out of q1
earnings season it's pretty well better
than expected by and large well much
better in the states that's for sure I
mean if you look at the S P 500
companies that have actually just
reported quite rightly as you've said
they're q1 I mean 80 of those companies
actually beat but what was more
importantly which I just overheard as I
was just coming in with your previous
actually interviewee about margins you
know input costs and that's more
important obviously going forward those
have been falling shipping costs are
falling oil prices are falling so
margins across all the sectors in the s
p were quite were quite strong and you
know everybody's looking for a recession
but you know they keep now now saying
it's being delayed despite these good
numbers and if you look at the UK Market
I looked this morning you know since we
think the bottom in the market was last
last Autumn but if you look at the UK
marketers in the stock market it's been
one of the strongest in the world world
it's been up 30 since the Autumn whereas
the rest of the world's only up 17 so
concerns about you know uh basically uh
hard Landing recession earnings I think
certainly it's like everything it's
between the the difference between
reality and expectations yeah you know
the expectations are that things are
horrible coming around the corner but
the reality is they're slightly better
than that and that's why the markets
continue to to do well and I think will
continue to do well probably a cruel
question to put you Patrick but I mean
do you think the UK Market is now
trading at closer to fair value I mean
obviously in terms of uh earnings
multiples it's been on a fairly low
valuation in recent times with the
historic average we actually quite like
the UK Market
um it's trading sort of um at a 12 15
discount to the rest of the world
um so it's certainly in The Bargain Bin
and there's a lot of bad news priced in
uh you're getting near four percent
yields while you wait and the ftse 100
ftse 250 is most probably actually more
domestic related and a lot of the retail
numbers that have been reported in the
UK have been quite buoyant so the
underlying consumer despite you know
worries about higher interest rates and
uh you know certainly the cost of living
increases are hanging certainly hanging
in there are there any sectors in
particular that you think represent
quite good value right now in the UK
well in the UK yes certainly I think you
know we've seen concerns about higher
rates and what that's going to do to
house builders Etc and I think you're
seeing a bottom out process if we're
right on interest rates then I think the
house builders especially consumer
discretionary stocks because there's
still a lot of savings left over from
covid and some of the numbers being
reported yesterday were fantastic in the
retail space so I think consumer
discretionary and house builders
certainly to us look really interesting
and the banks of course very interesting
Patrick we have to leave it there really
good to see in the studio this morning
thank you now the Prime Minister has
been meeting Executives from companies
developing artificial intelligence to
discuss how to mitigate the risks as
huge advances are made but according to
research from Coursera one of the
world's biggest online learning
platforms used for upskilling workers AI
is already being widely adopted in the
workplace with 80 percent of UK
Executives saying their business is
using it and nearly half doing so
extensively I've been speaking with Jeff
maggian Calder he's the chief executive
of Coursera we just did a survey of UK
businesses uh and just to sort of get a
level set of what's out there we were
surprised that 80 percent of UK
businesses surveyed said that they're
already implementing some kind of
generative AI mostly higher instances in
I.T and marketing uh quite high in legal
and also in financial services but it's
clearly a technology that companies are
integrating to provide better customer
service to boost productivity and to
really think of new ways to run their
businesses there is a bit of a skill
shortage around generative AI at the
moment how do businesses go about
addressing that
I think AI users again that's going to
kind of automatically come with the AI
electrification of the software tools
that we already used I think it'll be
pretty straightforward I don't know
there's going to be a lot of training to
use the tools but it will displace a lot
of jobs and so it will be required that
people get re-skilled and redeployed
into new jobs on the Builder's side
though yes there's a very high demand
for people who know how to build neural
networks who know how to build
adversarial networks who know how to use
this Transformer technology which is
kind of the under the architectural
underpinnings of things like chat GPT so
there's a huge demand and people will
both hire that kind of expertise which
is very expensive or they will build
that expertise using online training
courses like Coursera you've just put
your finger on a key Point uh though
which is a lot of people are very very
nervous about the ability of generative
AI to destroy jobs as well as create
them what would you say to people with
those anxieties
that they're not misplaced
I mean if you go back to the oecd in
2016 they did a study of the impact of
AI on jobs and when they said which
kinds of jobs will be impacted by the
kind of AI that existed in 2016 uh and
and they did it both by job and by
education level what they found was the
greatest level of impact would be held
by those with the least formal education
so the AI of 2016 mostly would impact
jobs held by people with no formal
education followed by people who have
just a high school degree followed by
people who have some college and then a
bachelor's and a master's and a PhD that
was as it stood with the technology in
2016. now fast forward to 2023 open Ai
and University of Pennsylvania just
published a study on March 27th looking
at the impact of this new kind of AI
this chat GPT generative Ai and they
said well which kinds of jobs will be
impacted by this new type of AI it was
the reverse order mostly it's going to
impact people with phds Master degrees
and bachelor's degrees it will have very
little impact on people with no formal
education but the technology in 2016
hasn't gone away so so the the those
with lower educational levels are still
at risk because of the more conventional
Ai and now the more advanced uh with the
knowledge jobs and the more advanced
technology with AI is going to impact
though so to some degree now we're all
in the same boat doesn't matter what
education level you have ai will impact
your jobs and that means we're all going
to have to be reskilling and retooling
and staying Nimble as as the world moves
forward now you've been very clear just
now that you think this is an
opportunity for your business so some of
your peers in the education sector such
as Chegg which recently put out a
profits warning are a bit less clear on
that
we just launched something called
Coursera coach it's a personal tutor
that sits there in the courses so that
you're not really alone every Learner in
the course will have somebody an expert
a learning assistant that they can talk
to and say I don't understand that give
me an example of that explain that in a
different way summarize that what career
would I pursue if I if I want if I had
this skill so it's it's like a
personalized learning assistant that you
can talk to that helps you with your
learning and it's it's extra I mean I'm
biased but I've been using it it's
extraordinary I mean it's it's
unbelievable uh then there's another
type of technology which is not so much
for the learner but for the content
producers our educator Partners like
Imperial College of London like
University of London
um like Leeds University where they can
use these tools that we have that we're
building a Coursera to make it easier
and faster to produce high quality
content and credentials now you've been
speaking uh I'm praising using chat GPT
during the course of this conversation
Google have just unveiled some
enhancements to their AI offering have
they still got time to close the gap on
Microsoft I think that there's not going
to be a single winner but I do think
that that Smart Companies today are not
betting on any one provider we have a
we're in the very early Innings and even
at Coursera you know we are architecting
our AI services for Learners and
partners to be multi-model so I really
think there'll be a number of models
that are good at different things and
there won't be just one big winner Terry
to make a statement on the net migration
and other migration figures today
Minister thank you Mr Speaker net
migration to the United Kingdom is far
too high that was already clear from the
previous set of official data the ons
have today amended their previous
published estimate of net migration for
the year ending June 2022 to 606 000.
the statistics published today indicate
that net migration has flatlined since
then
in the year ending December 2022 they
estimate that net migration remains at
606 000.
these particularly High figures are in
large part due to Temporary and
exceptional factors such as the UK's
Ukraine and Hong Kong bno schemes last
year more than 200 000 ukrainians and a
hundred and fifty thousand Hong Kong
British Nationals overseas made use of
the routes to life or time in the United
Kingdom these schemes command broad
support from the British public and we
were right to introduce them
the government remains committed to
reducing overall net migration to
sustainable levels that is a solemn
promise we made to the British public in
our Manifesto and we are unwavering in
our determination to deliver it
this week we announced steps to tackle
the substantial rise in the number of
student dependents coming to the UK
the package of measures will ensure that
we can reduce migration whilst
continuing to benefit from the skills
and resources our economy needs because
universities should be in the education
business not the immigration business
we expect this package to have a
tangible impact on net migration
taken together with the easing of
temporary factors like our exceptional
humanitarian offers we expect net
migration to fall to pre-pandemic levels
in the medium term
Mr Speaker the public rightly expect us
to control our borders whether that is
stopping the boats and addressing
illegal migration or whether it's
ensuring levels of legal migration do
not Place undue pressure on public
services on housing Supply or
integration the government is taking
decisive action on both counts under the
points-based system we introduced
post-brexit we can control immigration
we must control immigration and we will
Shadow Home Secretary
Mr Speaker today's extraordinary figures
including doubling the number of work
visas since the pandemic show that the
conservatives have no plan and no grip
on immigration they show the chaos in
this government work visas are 119 since
before the pandemic conservatives have
totally failed to tackle endemic skills
shortages and get people back to work
net migration is more than twice the
level that ministers were aiming for and
considerably more than that compared to
the home secretaries claimed aims the
Asylum backlog is at a record high the
opposite of the prime minister's promise
to clear the backlog this year and less
than one percent of last year's small
boat arrivals have had a decision yet
where is the Home Secretary who is in
charge of these policies she's gone to
ground there are reports she's not even
going to do media she's not come to this
house she's in internal media things
presumably more private courses arranged
by the civil servants what is the point
of her net migration should come down
and we would expect it to do so but the
continued gap between the government's
reality and the government's rhetoric
and the reality is very damaging rightly
the UK has given support to Ukraine and
Hong Kong as rightly we welcome
International students who bring
substantial benefits but changes on
family are sensible International
recruitment will also always be
important so we get the skills and
talent we need but this is a major
increase in employers turning to
overseas Recruitment and the government
has no plan to increase training or
properly tackle those skill shortages
from here at home so on Health and
Social care one of the biggest areas why
will he not agree to Labor's plan to
increase the training for nurses and
doctors in the UK paid for by getting
rid of the non-doms exemption will he
ditch the unfair 20 wage discount that
means shortage occupations can actually
undercut and pay below the going rate
making it even harder to get to the
training and the skills and the fair
recruitment that we need everyone should
be paid for the going rate Mr W speakers
Mr Mr Speaker there has been no action
at all to address the huge backlog in
the Asylum system and to make sure that
as claims are properly processed
we need immigration is important to this
country and we need a system that works
but it has to be properly controlled and
managed rather than the chaos that the
government has created
well thank you uh Mr Speaker the labor
party feigns interest in cutting net
migration but I can assure the right
honorable lady that nobody is buying it
last week the chair of the labor party
said that under labor net migration
would go up in the short term the leader
of the labor party stood on a campaign
pledge to defend freedom of movement if
the UK remained outside of the EU he
said that there is a racist undercurrent
which permeates all immigration laws
does the home the shadow Home Secretary
agree with them at every possible
opportunity labor have voted against
every measure that this government has
brought forward to control migration
they vote they voted against ending free
movement and at every turn they voted
against measures to tackle illegal
migration like just recently they voted
against the illegal migration bill
because the truth is Mr Speaker the
labor party have no interest in
controlled and orderly migration the
conservative party is taking tangible
steps to bring down net migration
yesterday we took a decisive step to
clamp down on student dependence because
universities should be selling education
not immigration belatedly the shadow
Home Secretary says she agrees with that
Mr Speaker the conservative party made a
solemn promise to the British public to
reduce net migration
thanks to brexit we now have the tools
at our disposal to do that we can and we
must deliver
the house of Peter bottom
well there you go you've been listening
to an urgent question uh being posed by
the shadow Home Secretary there Yvette
Cooper the gentleman answering that was
of course Robert generic the minister of
State for immigration we will have
response to that and more on this story
of course later on this morning here on
Sky News
in the meantime though the UK has been
one of the world's leading economies in
terms of reducing carbon emissions and
switching to low carbon energy sources
to that end another breakthrough was
achieved this week when the solar
technology specialist Oxford PV
announced it a set a new world record
for the amount of the sun's energy that
it can convert into electricity the
record-breaking solar cell converted
28.6 percent of the sun's energy into
electricity way ahead of the 22 to 24
achieved by comparable cells who are
joining me now is Dr Chris case he's
Chief technology officer at Oxford
photovoltaics Dr case welcome to you
this morning this is the second such a
record that you've set in as many years
I gather
it is indeed a second record in about
just over 12 months time but we've been
setting records traditionally around
this new technology since our Inception
in the work on this Innovative solar
cell that was developed
now this material uh this cell uses an
ultra thin layer of material called
perovskite without getting too technical
on me can you perhaps explain what it
does
well you know I know you like sometimes
showing show and tells this stuff is
silicon that's the material that all
those solar cells that make up the solar
modules you see on rooftops consist of
and this is the stuff we use it's
actually synthesized chemical
based on a mineral as discovered back in
1839 but entirely synthesized material
but it's a far more effective solar
absorber meaning it can take those solar
photons and convert them to electrons
with much less material in fact
something like one two hundredth the
amount of material at that conventional
silicon requires
now the clue of course to the company is
in the name you're a spin-off from the
University of Oxford but this so was
actually manufactured in Brandenburg in
Germany I gather
that that's correct so we have two
locations we have our sort of
headquarters and r d Center just north
of Oxford and we were a 2000 spin-off
from the University but we've had a
manufacturing site in Germany just west
of Berlin since 2017.
so the money is how important is the
manufacturing in the sort of whole
value-added process people will sort of
say well if the intellectual property
resides here in the UK why doesn't the
manufacturing
well I mean look a manufacturing the
decision to manufacture somewhere takes
account a variety of decisions you've
got to have plan space you know a
streamlined permitting process of course
the availability of the necessary waiver
and of course you need financing and to
a certain extent if there are incentives
available these go into a package that
goes into your decision making about
locating uh Germany was a very
attractive package for us back in 2017
to locate our first manufacturing site I
mean you know the discussion around
decarbonization traditionally has been
with associated with climate crisis but
since the Russian sort of invasion of
the Ukraine last year the dialogue has
changed to about energy security and
bringing manufacturing back to uh to
local areas I mean today
virtually 95 percent of the panels that
are installed you know anywhere in the
world are sourced and supplied by China
so if you want to have a local sourcing
you've got to have local manufacturer
ring so I think it is very important
that we figure out ways to encourage
local manufacturing a PV wherever that
may be in our hometowns in the UK or
within Europe or elsewhere within the
West
now there's been a lot of talk about uh
potential IPO of the business I gather
you're looking more at Hong Kong or New
York than London well let me just sort
of back away from that a little bit in
the sense that we're not ready to
announce anything like that I mean we're
just over over 12 years old as a company
obviously we're venture-backed and
everybody's always looking to grow and
seek future opportunities and we'll make
decisions about where to do or what our
future uh Direction might be based on
you know decisions and finances that are
available going forward but for us to
grow further we do have to build new
manufacturing plants so absolutely for
sure on our mind is where to locate the
next manufacturing plant
very good it's been fascinating talking
to you this morning Dr case thank you
for giving us a glimpse of the
technology as well hope to see you again
thank you okay very good thank you
[Music]
trying to have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with
yesterday's Rising guilt yields which is
of course an implied government
borrowing cost that came after the April
inflation figure was higher than
expected well inside the ft's economics
editor Chris Giles writes that while the
return of high inflation and slow growth
draws comparisons with the 1970s things
are actually a bit different this time
the ft is currently leading its Digital
Editions meanwhile with off-gen's
reduction in the energy price cap well
the times carries on its business front
page report on comments yesterday from
Amanda Blanc the chief executive of the
insurer Aviva in which she criticized
proposals to compel UK Pension funds to
invest their members Savings in British
startups and other potentially fast
growth unlisted businesses but it leads
its business pages with the rise in
Guild yields so too does The Daily
Telegraph but also on its front page are
comments yesterday from Andrew Bailey in
which the bank of England's Governor
called for more risk-taking in the city
warning that without it the economy
could suffer longer term we've talked a
lot on this program recently about
artificial intelligence indeed we were
earlier today and the potential it has
for disrupting a whole host of
Industries and businesses but disruption
is something with which businesses have
always lived inflation is another key
challenge right now well not so long ago
it was supply chain disruption due to
the pandemic so how do businesses steer
their way through such situations well
the consultancy Alex Partners advises a
wide range of companies in differing
stages of transition and joining in our
very pleased to say Simon freakley the
chief executive Simon welcome to you
inflation obviously the Hot Topic right
now do you see much evidence if
businesses adapting successfully to it
thanks Ian well of course inflation is
top of mind for everybody you know even
though the IMF says that we know we're
now below double digits in the UK when
you look at core inflation particularly
food inflation it's still well into the
double digits so I think extraordinary
pressures on not just the consumer but
also on business so for every chief
executive not just in the UK but
internationally inflation is top of mind
but also of course other profound
disruptions you know what's happening
you know because of environmental
pressures and expectations what's
happening in terms of Technology
accelerations talk about generative AI
I'm sure but these disruptions are
layering on top of each other are
proving extremely challenging for
boardrooms and chief Executives they
really are I mean another Hot Topic is
the tightness of Labor markets we've
we've had the migration numbers out this
morning I mean what are you telling
companies right now in terms of how they
handle this well I mean it is still a
tight labor market but an even tighter
skills Market if you look at where the
real pressure is in labor is a small
cotery particularly digital skills that
are so hard to get hold of and as
businesses try and evolve their business
models at speed to stay relevant getting
enough of these skills is critical so
what we say to our clients is make sure
that you're using technology to enhance
the productivity of your labor force
because that's the way to stay ahead
well technology takes me on to AI is
this an opportunity or a threat to most
businesses you know I think generative
AI is going to comprehensively disrupt
every business in every Market you know
it's a bit like seeing an asteroid
that's about to hit the planet because
chat GPT has just you know become
publicly known uh over a hundred million
users in two months the most the
quickest adapted app ever in the history
of apps so I think a technology
generally and generative AI particularly
is going to comprehensively rethink
every business every job you've spoken
in the recent past about the minefields
that uh what is acceptable in the
workplace and what isn't anymore the
threats that poses to to CEOs what have
you made of events at the CBI recently
you know I think that um
and you know what happened to the CVS
CBI was never right uh of course in this
day and age with social media playing
such an important part in our worlds
because so much is known so quickly by
so many I think the uh the qualities of
leadership the essential qualities of
leadership about values and purpose and
how one behaves remain critical as they
always were but you know for companies
that aren't purpose uh LED leadership
that isn't values based I think
ultimately it catches them out but we've
just seen for example John Allen he's
had to stand down as chairman of both
Tesco and Barrett developments for
things that he vehemently denies I mean
a board shooting first and asking
questions later you know and John just
had a just such a successful career as a
businessman and I have no idea of course
about the allegations and can't comment
on them but what a a first-class
business person but obviously these
allegations are serious and have to be
addressed and I'm sure they will be I
mean it puts a wider point though onto
sort of the generational gaps that we're
seeing in workforces right now gen Zed
and to an extent the Millennials see the
world very differently from gen x's and
and Boomers what sort of challenges does
that pose for for Business Leaders it's
so interesting Ian you know I often say
to our clients that Chief Executives
have to be their own Chief communication
officers because they people have to be
clear their customers their employees
their future employees their suppliers
have to be clear what the company stands
for what the chief executive stands for
and that isn't something that could be
delegated to somebody else I think one
of the great pressures on leaders is
they have to be right on their front
thought what is their position on social
justice what is their position on the
environment because their stakeholders
really care about these things it makes
the pressures on CEOs are just ever
growing on that basis what do you make
of what Julia hoggets just said at the
London Stock Exchange that CEOs in this
country are not being paid enough
well I think this is always a relative
test I think by reference the majority
of the world CEOs are paid very nicely
but you know there is a lot of pressure
on CEOs we do a review every year
interview 3 000 Chief Executives around
the world we've just finished this
year's survey and what it shows is that
CEOs are more concerned than they've
ever been about the pressures on them to
act and act quickly now I sometimes joke
that what we call the disruption index
should be called the anxiety index
because CEOs markedly are more concerned
than they've ever been about losing
their jobs they thought they're in the
hot seat they now found that in the
ejector seat and so I think there's a
lot of pressure on Executives all right
Simon gotta leave it there I'm afraid
good to see you this morning come back
and see us again soon thank you
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning hope very much to see
you then in the meantime after this
short break Jane sucker is up with the
latest on the migration numbers do stay
tuned cheerio
[Music]